c'est toujours leur de barbarie ça avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie télécharge l'api jeter
gris et tente de remporter jusqu'à un
million d'euros sans rien faire bravo
l'auto facile d'être riche et
l'intention tirez vous avez une 1ère
question pour moi oui absolument
pour qu'elle livre andré malraux at il
remporté le prix interallié en 1930
andré prix interallié est un prix
littéraire qui diront qu'on pense
alarmant de jéhovah dire je vous dis
tout dans cette émission sachez qu
apparemment des personnes en vol à ma
vie là julien de bien vouloir venir près
de moi merci pour cette question sans
julien tu pourrais me reposer la
question s'il vous plaît j'aurais
peut-être la question pour quelle libre
andré malraux at il remporté le prix
interallié en 1930 la voie royale
c'est ça incroyable
[Applaudissements]
je peux que julien une très belle mais
je pense qu'il a été faire les soldes
off alors autre question oui je sais
vous de ça des droits non je pense que
c'est l'espoir non l'espoir l'on sait
bien après tout la balle au bond
[Musique]